we have a a story here that's very
interesting tomorrow is Black Friday
yeah today is turkey day and this is you
know we're we're all into football today
right yeah Tom you have no idea how much
I want to get in a food fight with you
right now I thought maybe you're going
to bust it out throw some mashed potato
come on sorry Tom we can do that later
baby um yeah that's right so check this
out Amazon is paying
$100 million for the broadcast rights to
one game and it's the Black Friday game
and Black Friday is on Friday and Sh in
the dark and by the way they've never
done that because the NFL never does a
Black Friday game for two reasons it was
a holiday people are going shopping and
the other thing you ready for this the
sports broadcasting Act of 1961 which is
federal law prohibited the NFL from
putting games on Fridays after 6:00
because they were protecting college and
high school football and they felt that
that was an important tradition for
America Amer and they didn't want to let
televis commercialization football do it
well why did Amazon buy this check this
out Amazon paid $100 million for the
game and they checked in that they
weren't breaking the law if they
broadcast the game at 3:00 so it was
over by 6 o00 so why are they putting
this game this game is going to be on
Amazon Prime but you you know who's
playing
though Miami Dolphins baby versus the
New York Jets Miami got the dolphin by
way way you were you made an amazing uh
with the and by the way NFL usually
destroys ratings on Thanksgiving the
average Thanksgiving Day NFL game for
the past four years has been 33 million
viewers the NBA Christmas Day game has
never exceeded 5 million viewers wow not
comparable not comparable so why did
Amazon pay $100 million for one game
step one they're going to watch
everybody can watch it on Amazon for
free it not to not to Prime people
remember it used to be you had to pay
for Amazon Prime to get Thursday Night
Football from Amazon
that is it that it now here comes here
comes the crazy thing they're charging
advertisers $880,000 for 30 seconds damn
the normal NFL game outside of playoffs
is 440,000 double the price double the
price and they're doing get this
audience-based creative you're going to
be watching it on the Amazon channel
right for free if you are an Amazon
Prime user you're going to get these ads
if you're not an Amazon Prime user
you're going to get different ads that
are tailored to you Bose has signed up
and there will be three different ads
Joe burrow will go to the nonprime uh
viewers and the other Bose ads will
there and while you're watching the game
check this out Pat you can click on the
screen and put the product in your
shopping with without turning away from
the game making some sales and personal
profit P they will be they will be
retargeting they estimate that Amazon is
probably going to net net net do on this
they're probably not going to lose money
it's probably a $2 billion payday so Tom
there it is so you're saying if the
camera Cuts I'm watching it on my phone
and it cuts to the cheerleaders and I'm
like damn I want that skirt I could just
hit it um I you can hit it all right I
think some of the problem but the point
is Amazon is bringing
together football shopping Black Friday
and Technology pretty smart and families
Tom and and but look at this I mean I
just think we were talking about AI at
the of the show look at all the
technology and AI That's that's
literally in the background here and and
Amazon goes knock knock knock to NFL
says can't I pay 100,000 for a game on
Friday they turn to each other and say
heang on a second Louie this is so easy
yeah yeah sure please wire that right
over we'll give you the Dolphins on on
Black Friday so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right
here a